Speaker 1: All right. One more story before we
move on to other things sort of in this world of
election fraud and claims and riots
and all these different things.
Former White House counsel Norm Eisen is
now saying that he believes Trump is likely
to be prosecuted in Georgia. And this I got
a bunch of emails about this. This is sort of
separate from the Trump riot hearings. This is
this is specifically in the state of Georgia.
Business Insider reporting, former White House
special counsel says Trump is likely to be
prosecuted in Georgia because of particularly
strong evidence. Former President Donald Trump
could be prosecuted in Georgia for his attempts
to overturn the state's election results in 2020.
Norm Eisen, former White House special counsel
for ethics, told CNN it's likely Trump will be
prosecuted because of particularly strong
evidence. Quote, I think the evidence is
particularly strong for a prosecution in the
state of Georgia, where the Atlanta D.A. has
convened a special grand jury. Remember that?
That's where Fulton County D.A., Fannie Willis,
wanted a special grand jury to look at Trump's
attempts to overturn the election there.
The grand jury was convened last month. You have
to recall that this is the state in which Trump
wanted those 11,780 votes that he didn't earn.
Speaker 2: I need 11,000 votes. Give me a break.
Speaker 1: And that is very, very strong
evidence. It's a clear attempt to extort.
This was after the third recount in
December of 2020, which confirmed, again,
Joe Biden won Georgia. You might remember
that Georgia took a while to flip to blue
on the map that most media outlets
were using because it was being
challenged in a more real way than what was
being done in other states. Joe Biden won it
and Donald Trump is on a recording after we knew
that he had lost. Saying, Find me the votes,
saying there's nothing wrong with saying,
hey, you've recalculated. And now look,
it turns out that Donald Trump actually won. And
remember that when the Georgia secretary of state
wouldn't go with it. And I don't believe that the
Georgia secretary of state is great in any way,
but he was unwilling to go with it. Donald
Trump then started the mob boss type underhanded
threats. Listen, this is going to be costly in
many ways, Trump said. Costly in many ways. It
is straight up mob vocabulary, and he's
recorded doing it. So the question now,
this is parallel to the January 6th investigation.
Is there going to be an indictment? Are there
going to be charges coming out of Georgia? And
I know listen, I'm with everybody. Even if you
get charges, it doesn't necessarily mean anything
major is going to happen. But charging a former
president is a really big deal if they're just
there, being charges would be a major, major deal.
We will have all of these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
Bottom line it for me at the end of the day, where
are you right now? Does Trump get charged anywhere
federally? Georgia, Pennsylvania, just any?
Will there be any charges against Trump or not?
Let me know your thoughts in a comment and a
tweet in an email to info at David Pakman dot com.